you you have a very important campaign
right now and it's called get real about
diabetes I actually have a couple
friends that are diabetic which serious
thing so what can you tell us about it
what do you mean by get real uh get real
about diabetes I partnered with Novo
Nordisk a little more than five years
ago to bring awareness to people with
type 2 diabetes I've been a type 2
diabetic for 21 years now uh and uh as a
diabetic it's more than just you know
monitoring your glucose and your blood
sugar levels it's also uh worrying and
being conscious of the other things that
happen which is cardiovascular disease
yeah and unfortunately I lost my father
uh to cardiovascular disease from
complications of being a diabetic so
it's about me just giving my testimonial
out there to people and and driving them
uh to uh our website you know you can
Google get real about diabetes and and
and see what it's about but as a type 2
diabetic I'm four times as likely to
have a stroke or cardior vascular
disease or a heart attack scary uh so I
just want to educate people about the
things and if you can look at the
transformation that I've made now it's
because of that and you know what though
a lot of people
what is your main motivation for that a
lot of people need to be motivated or
obviously life and you don't want
anything that could happen but I don't
know I feel like people can tell you
doctors can tell you left and right like
this is wrong this is wrong you should
make this changes make change you're
like got it
um but what what do you think made you
finally do it uh one losing my father uh
to my mother being diagnosed with type 2
diabetes as well I was the first person
diagnosed in my family with it oh my
gosh uh and just learning to live with
the disease and not die from it yeah you
know uh because I look around and I see
uh what happens to people who go
unchecked and don't check themselves
like my dad was and it's just about
sharing uh this information you know
February is American Heart month uh and
and so that's why I'm really out there
talking about it you know to get people
motivated to get people moving to make a
change in their life uh just to do uh
healthier things absolutely
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]